Netflix puts billions of dollars into new
content every year, but while everyone hears
about buzzy releases like Orange Is the New
Black and House of Cards, the sheer amount
of content means other shows get lost in the
shuffle.
To help out, here are a bunch of upcoming
Netflix originals that are going to blow you
away.
Disjointed
Kathy Bates is getting high for Disjointed,
a comedy in which she stars as Ruth, "a woman
whose lifelong mission has been to decriminalize
marijuana."
The series finds Ruth running a Los Angeles-area
marijuana dispensary—and finding that business
is much, much harder when you're stoned.
Disjointed, which released a teaser on 4/20,
will premiere its 20-episode first season
on August 25th.
David Javerbaum of The Daily Show co-created
the comedy alongside Chuck Lorre, and a strong
supporting cast rounds out the ensemble.
Hold the Dark
Adapted from the William Giraldi 2014 novel
of the same name, Hold the Dark focuses on
the pursuit of a wolf responsible for killing
children in the Alaskan wilderness, and stars
Alexander Skarsgard and Westworld's Jeffrey
Wright
Hold the Dark comes from director Jeremy Saulnier,
the man behind the critically acclaimed thriller
Green Room.
While Hold the Dark doesn't yet have a release
date, it started production in early 2017,
so hopefully Saulnier will be back to terrify
viewers soon.
Green Eggs and Ham
Netflix's adaptation of Dr. Seuss' Green Eggs
and Ham will follow the book's characters
Guy and Sam as they "take a road trip to save
an endangered animal."
Along the way, they learn about friendship—and,
of course, green eggs and ham.
Ellen DeGeneres' attachment as an executive
producer is already a great sign for Green
Eggs and Ham, which, despite the book's popularity,
has yet to be adapted into a film or TV series,
aside from the 1973 special Dr. Seuss on the
Loose.
Netflix has stayed pretty quiet about the
show since greenlighting it in 2015, but their
website notes that its 13-episode first season
is expected to debut in 2018.
The Irishman
With an estimated budget of over $100 million,
The Irishman is one of Netflix's priciest
upcoming projects, but one that's definitely
worth the price—it reunites Martin Scorsese
with Robert De Niro, along with a rumored
supporting cast of heavy hitters like Al Pacino,
Joe Pesci, and Harvey Keitel.
The Irishman stars De Niro as Frank "The Irishman"
Sheeran, the mob hitman allegedly responsible
for the death of Jimmy Hoffa.
"It's about Hoffa, um.
Basically it's the guy confesses that he had
killed Hoffa."
With a huge amount of talent on both sides
of the camera, this movie will surely be on
your radar—and in your queue—soon.
Lost in Space
Netflix is setting out to remake the popular
1960s series Lost in Space,.
You know, this one:
"It crashed over there.
Come on, let's take a look."
"Danger, Will Robinson.
Danger."
The show will follow a new cast on the spaceship
Jupiter 2, which is stranded light years away
from its original destination after a crash.
Cast member Toby Stephens calls it a "very
clever, modern reworking" of the original
show's story.
The 10-episode reboot is expected out in 2018.
Little Evil
This horror comedy stars Adam Scott and Evangeline
Lilly as a newly married couple with a son...
who just might be the Antichrist.
In addition to a fun premise and a great cast,
Little Evil has some impressive people working
behind the scenes, with Tucker and Dale vs.
Evil writer/director Eli Craig once again
pulling double duty for his first feature
since that 2010 cult hit.
The movie is expected to debut in 2017.
Mute
Hold the Dark isn't Alexander Skarsgard's
only upcoming Netflix film.
He'll also star in Mute.
Skarsgard plays Leo, a mute bartender living
in a near-future Berlin who embarks on a mission
through the city's seedy underbelly to try
and find his missing girlfriend.
Mute is the second film in a sci-fi trilogy
from director Duncan Jones, who says it's
set in the same universe as his 2009 cult
favorite Moon.
Jones says he plans for Mute to imagine Berlin
the way Blade Runner depicted Los Angeles—just
one more reason it'll definitely be one to
watch when it debuts later this year.
Game Over, Man!
The Workaholics gang will reunite for Game
Over, Man!, an action comedy featuring Blake
Anderson, Anders Holm, and Adam Devine as
three friends "on the verge of getting their
video game financed when their benefactor
is taken hostage by terrorists."
Seth Rogen is set to produce the film alongside
his writing partner Evan Goldberg, and Kyle
Newacheck, the co-creator of Workaholics,
will direct based on a script from Anders
Holm.
IO
This sci-fi movie tells the story of Sam Walde,
a teen who finds herself one of the few survivors
on a post-apocalyptic Earth.
Sam is played by The Nice Guys' Margaret Qualley,
and Anthony Mackie—who you'll recognize
as The Avengers' Falcon—co-stars as Micah,
a fellow refugee on his way to the last human
shuttle leaving Earth.
Danny Huston, recently spotted in DC's Wonder
Woman, will also appear in an undisclosed
role.
There's no word yet on when the movie will
premiere, although filming took place in late
2016, so hopefully IO will be here to get
all of our hearts racing soon.
Big Mouth
Netflix's upcoming animated comedy Big Mouth
follows comedian Nick Kroll's time as an awkward
teenager growing up with his best friend Andrew
Goldberg, now a writer and producer for Family
Guy.
Kroll voices himself, with fellow standup
John Mulaney playing Goldberg.
Kroll calls the show "over 30 years in the
making," and he's clearly using his comedy
connections to round out the cast—he's recruited
an impressive roster that includes Maya Rudolph,
Jordan Peele, Fred Armisen, and Jenny Slate.
The series is expected out in 2017.
Gerald's Game
There are about a billion Stephen King adaptations
in the works, and Netflix is joining the arena
with Gerald's Game, starring Watchmen's Carla
Gugino as a woman stranded in her lakeside
home after a sex game gone wrong.
Gerald's Game doesn't have a release date
yet, but it boasts an accomplished horror
director in Mike Flanagan.
Flanagan also has King's full support—Gugino
has said that King was a big fan of Flanagan's
Hush and gave him his blessing in pursuing
the project.
King is also apparently pretty happy with
the early cut, tweeting in February of this
year that the movie is "horrifying, hypnotic,
terrific."
Another Stephen King adaptation in the works
at Netflix, 1922 stars an actor familiar with
the bestselling author's work: Thomas Jane,
who led the 2003 film adaptation of King's
Dreamcatcher and the 2007 adaptation of The
Mist.
Jane plays Wilfred James, a man who admits
to killing his wife with the help of his teenage
son.
After her death, he starts to believe that
she's haunting him.
Altered Carbon
Based on the 2002 novel by Richard K. Morgan,
Altered Carbon focuses on Takeshi Kovacs,
a former elite warrior who's been imprisoned
for 500 years before his mind is downloaded
into someone else's body to solve a murder.
Suicide Squad star Joel Kinnaman will take
on the role of Kovacs, starring opposite Kristin
Lehman and James Purefoy.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!